when season one of the witcher dropped
on netflix back in december 2019 it was
an instant smash hit
while there were some differences
between the series and the video games
most fans believed it to be a faithful
adaptation of author andre sapkowski's
books upon which the cd projekt red
games are based a standout for many
viewers was the brilliant casting of
superman actor henry cavill in the lead
role of geralt to rivia
the show follows geralt as well as the
sorceress jennifer of wengerberg and the
crown princess siri
as they go through various events at
different points in time based heavily
on sapkowski's the last wish and sort of
destiny
their characters go through formative
events that shape them into the legends
they are to become until all of their
stories eventually merge
the first season was well received by
critics and audiences alike and
expectations are high going
into season two especially after the
overwhelming season one finale
appropriately titled much more while
fans are eager to see the continuing
adventures of geralt and friends some
unfortunate news has emerged from the
production
according to sources close to the
witcher's production cavill has suffered
injuries that have sidelined him for the
moment
although filming has still continued for
scenes that don't include him as
detailed in a report first published by
the sun and later in follow-up coverage
from deadline
cavill suffered a leg injury while he
was shooting something at arbor field
studios in london
reports indicate that cabell was doing
his own stunts 20 feet into the air
while wearing a safety harness and
that's when the injury took place
the expectation is that cavill will
remain sidelined for a short period of
time while production on the witcher
continues shooting scenes that don't
require him
the sun published quotes from an
anonymous source who described how the
injury transpired
the filming has been hit because of what
happened to henry he was on an assault
course and injured his leg
he just suddenly pulled up and was
clearly in a lot of pain it wasn't clear
if an object had hit his leg or if it
was some sort of hamstring or muscle
injury
it wasn't bad enough to need an
ambulance but it's messed up the filming
schedule as he can't walk properly
he has to wear heavy armor in the scenes
and he just won't be able to do that
with this leg injury
similar to many other productions the
witcher is expected to go on hiatus for
the holidays later in december so
production would stop soon regardless of
what happened at cabell
with the extra time off hopefully cattle
has plenty of time to rest up and enter
production in 2021 feeling good and
healthy
2020 has been a rough year for residents
of the kingdom of sintra
as was the case with most film and
television productions this year the
witcher had to halt filming as a result
of the covet 19 pandemic
not only did this push things back but
it also made it so that not everyone
from the first season could come back to
reprise their roles
turas musun who played escola on the
witcher season 1 had to drop out of the
second season due to scheduling
conflicts that came about from the
coronavirus delay
the covet 19 pandemic also hit
particularly close to home for the
witcher cast and crew when actor
christopher heavyweight tested positive
for the disease back in march
the pause in filming first began in
march and lasted until august
filming resumed for a little while
before halting again in november after
several more positive covet 19 cases
came about within the production
it's been touch and go for the witcher
for almost an entire year now and
hopefully once production gets back on
its feet with cavill and the saddle
again things will go smoothly from there
on out
fortunately the production is able to
carry on without cavill for the time
being so fingers crossed that things
won't get pushed back too much
as of right now the witcher season 2 is
slated to come out sometime in 2021 but
keep checking back to looper as more
details emerge in the coming months
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one